je suis sûr qu'il y en a un par là
en tout cas
l'année dernière il y en avait un
il est là et
Et voilà, tous mes œufs sont dans le même panier.
Mais au fait pourquoi mange-t-on des oeufs enchocolat à pâques ?
Allez ! Dans l'atelier, je vaisvous expliquer le coup du lapin,
en chocolat biensûr.
L’origine des œufs de Pâques remonte
sans doute à des milliers d’années.
L'œuf représente, eneffet, l'origine de la vie
ou la renaissance dansde nombreuses civilisations.
Chez les Perses, les Egyptiens ou encore les Gaulois,
il était donccoutumier d'offrir des œufs,
parfois décorés, au moment du printemps
quand la nature renaît.
Regardez ce qu'on m'a offert.
Joliment décoré non ?
Cette tradition printanière est aussi
celle de la Pâque dans la religion chrétienne.
Les premiers chrétiens se seraient en effet offerts des œufs à Pâques
pour symboliser la résurrection du Christ.
Et oui, finalement il est sorti de sa tombe comme
la vie sort sort de l’œuf !
Puis, à partir du Moyen-Âge, la tradition
serait devenue encore plus forte, à cause du Carême.
Vous savez, cette période de jeûne avant Pâques
pendant laquelle il était interdit de consommer de la viande, des œufs.
Au lieu de les jeter, ils étaient vidés,
décorés et offerts le dimanche de Pâques !
Et les cloches dans tout ça ?
J'y viens.
En France, comme les cloches des églises sont condamnées au silence en signe de deuil entre le jeudi saint et le dimanche de Pâques,
les adultes auraient inventé une histoire
pour faire rêver les enfants :
les cloches des églises partiraient  le jeudi,
à Rome, pour se faire bénir par le Pape
et déposeraient leurs œufs en revenant le dimanche.
Chez nos voisins d’Outre-Rhin en Allemagne,
c’est le lapin ou le lièvre,
les symboles païens de la fertilité,
qui se chargent de cacher les œufs dans le jardin.
Ce n’est cependant qu’à partir de la seconde
moitié du 19è siècle
que les chocolatiers ont l’idée de proposer des œufs de Pâques
entièrement en chocolat et progressivement,
des lapins, des poules et tout un tas d’autres friandises chocolatées.
Hmm, c'est bon !
Mais comment fabrique-t-on du chocolat ?
Allez, direction la cuisine on va voir ça sur la planche.
Pour faire du chocolat, il faut d’abord récolter
les fruits d’un arbre tropical : le cacaoyer.
Il donne des cabosses, comme celle-ci. A l’intérieur,
se cachent des graines: on parle de fèves de cacao.
Une cabosse peut en contenir une soixantaine.
T’en as dans la cabosse toi !
Une fois récupérées, les fèves, qui au départ,
sont enrobées de pulpe,
sont mises à fermenter pendant quelques jours
puis séchées au soleil pendant deux semaines.
Vient alors l’étape de la torréfaction :
les fèves sont chauffées jusqu’à 130°C environ une demi-heure.
Il ne reste plus alors qu’à les broyer pour
obtenir une pâte de cacao.
Cette pâte de cacao est ensuite pressée et aussi étrange
que cela puisse paraître, on en extrait du beurre du beurre de cacao.
Puis avec la partie sèche, débarrassé de son beurre,
que l'on dit maintenant "maigre".
Cette partie sèche est broyé et on obtient de la poudre.
C'est amer ! Enfin amer, je parle de l'amertume.
Et c’est à ce stade que la fabrication du chocolat,
tel qu'on le déguste, peut réellement commencer.
Pour faire du chocolat noir, on mélange du sucre et du cacao maigre.
On malaxe pendant plusieurs heures
en ajoutant au fur et à mesure du beurre de cacao.
C’est ce qu’on appelle le "conchage"
dans le jargon des chocolatiers.
Durant cette étape, chaque particule chocolatée
s’enrobe d'un film gras.
C'est ce qui permet d’obtenir un chocolat onctueux et fondant.
Quant il sort des malaxeurs, le mélange avoisinne 75°C.
Il est refroidi en plusieurs étapes.
C'est Indispensable pour devenir brillant et croquant
tout en restant fondant.
C’est ce que les spécialistes appellent le "tempérage".
Ben dis donc faut être patient.
Je commence à broyer du noir moi  Pas vous ?
Et je n'ai pas encore tout dit.
A propos du chocolat noir justement,
plus il y a de pate de cacao, cacao maigre et beurre de cacao,
plus le pourcentage est élevé.
C'est écrit sur la tablette, 70% pour celui-ci.
Pour faire du chocolat au lait maintenant,
on prend les même ingrédients et ajoute du lait en poudre.
Pour le chocolat blanc, c’est encore différent.
Ce n’est pas vraiment du chocolat, il ne contient pas de pâte de cacao.
Seulement du beurre de cacao, du sucre et du lait en poudre.
Moi j’adore le chocolat noir.
Et vous ? Lequel préférez-vous ?
Dites-le moi en commentaire, ça me fera plaisir !
Personne me parle à moi ! Y’en a que pour l’autre.
Quoiqu’il en soit savez-vous qu’à l’origine,
le chocolat est en fait une boisson.
Et même, d’après des scientifiques une boisson alcoolisée !
Je vous explique.
Le chocolat est originaire d’Amérique centrale.
Les archéologues américain en ont retrouvé des traces au Honduras,
dans de la vaisselle vieille de plus de 3000 ans.
A l’époque, cette boisson était obtenue grâce
à la fermentation de la pulpe qui entoure la fève de cacao.
Les Mayas et les Aztèques ont ensuite eu l’idée
d’utiliser la fève de cacao tout entière,
en la faisant sécher, griller puis en la broyant ...
Vous connaissez la recette.
Afin d’obtenir une pâte qu’ils mélangeaient avec de l’eau
pour obtenir une boisson nommée « xocoatl ».
C’est de ce mot que viendrait le terme « chocolate » en espagnol,
puis « chocolat » en français.
Quand les Européens débarquent en Amérique à la fin du 15e siècle,
ils ignorent tout du cacao et de cette boisson.
Ils ignorent aussi qu’elle sert de monnaie à l’époque.
L’histoire raconte même que des marchands mayas
auraient offert des fèves de cacao à Christophe Colomb
qui n’y aurait absolument pas prêté attention, on raconte même qu'il les aurait confonduavec des crottes de chèvre.
Vous vous rendez compte à cause de lui,
l’histoire du chocolat aurait pu être étouffée dans l’œuf !
Au 16è siècle, Hernan Cortés rapporte la boisson
en Espagne, où elle fait fureur.
Dans sa version européenne : on y ajoute du sucre,
du lait ou de la vanille pour en adoucir l’amertume.
Le breuvage gagne ensuite la France, grâce à Marie-Thérèse d’Autriche,
infante d’Espagne qui épouse Louis XIV.
Accro au chocolat elle en rapporte dans ses valises.
Bien évidemment, ce qui se fait à la cour devient vite une mode et le chocolat conquiert l’aristocratie Française !
Depuis il s’est démocratisé. Tablettes, pâte à tartiner,
confiserie, chocolat en poudre.
En France, nous consommons chaque année de 325 000 tonnes de chocolat.
Dont 15 000 tonnes en chocolat de Pâques.
Ça en fait des lapins et des poules.
Mmmh c’est bon ! Et en plus ça fait du bien.
Pas étonnant. i il contient au moins 70% de cacao et
le chocolat noir est bon pour la santé.
Le cacao est riche en flavonoïdes, des substances
aux multiples bienfaits qui font baisser la tension artérielle,
protègent le cœur et les artères, aident à lutter contre le déclin cognitif.
Le cacao protègerait aussi le foie et enfin,
il serait bon pour le moral,
grâce au magnésium qu’il contient mais aussi
parce qu’il favorise la sécrétion d’endorphines,
des messagers du bonheur et de la détente
dans notre cerveau.
Bon alors, l'œuf ou la poule ?
Quoiqu'une petite oreille de lapin ...
En attendant de savoir qui je vais croquer,
rendez-vous sur le compte Instagram ou la page Facebook "Épicurieux"
pour tenter de gagner un délicieux coffret
de chocolat pour Pâque.
Tenez, à l'intérieur, il y a même une tablette de chocolat
personnalisé Épicurieux.
Je suis sûr que vous allez adorer le goût du savoir.